la fibromialgia es un trastorno crónico
que afecta a 5 millones de
estadounidenses en su mayoría mujeres-
se caracteriza por un sueño no reparador
así como por dolor y rigidez muscular
que puede durar todo el día
dolor en los cuatro cuadrantes del
cuerpo y presencia de puntos sensibles
específicos aunque el dolor de la
fibromialgia puede variar en intensidad
las personas que lo padecen a menudo lo
describen como un dolor persistente y
profundo o como un dolor muscular
punzante o lacerante otros síntomas
comunes incluyen fatiga incapacitante
insomnio dolor en las articulaciones
calambres en las piernas dolor de cabeza
y problemas de concentración y memoria
conocidos como fibro niebla
puesto que no existe un examen de
laboratorio o una radiografía para
confirmar el diagnóstico de fibromialgia
en cierto momento les hicieron creer a
algunos pacientes que el dolor estaba en
sus mentes
hoy en día diversos investigadores
piensan que el cerebro y médula espinal
procesan los mensajes de dolor de forma
incorrecta lo que ocasiona que los
pacientes con fibromialgia sientan el
dolor con más intensidad uno de los
aspectos únicos de la fibromialgia es la
presencia de puntos sensibles en lugares
específicos del cuerpo cuando se
presionan estos puntos las personas con
fibromialgia sienten dolor mientras que
las personas sin el síndrome solo
sienten presión para que un paciente sea
diagnosticado con fibromialgia éste debe
estar sensible a por lo menos 11 de los
18 posibles puntos sensibles y
experimentar dolor generalizado en los
cuatro cuadrantes del cuerpo